alrighty folks so i went and i saw the
new james bond movie i am a daniel craig
bond fan we'll get to my review in just
one second this video is sponsored by
expressvpn
[Music]
so let me begin with what daniel craig's
bond is so he's a much more soulful bond
than prior bonds right some of them are
sort of erotic like roger moore some of
them are sort of halfway in between like
pierce brosnan daniel craig's bond is a
very sincere bond meaning that he is
sort of a hard-nosed battle-scarred
ex-soldier who is very stylish and is
doing cool things and i will admit he is
my favorite bond i really like daniel
craig as bond i think casino royale is a
truly terrific movie i think it's the
best bond movie period i don't think any
of the others have really met it i think
skyfall was the second best and this one
is probably the third best maybe so i
have some serious problems with this
film the opening sequence of the film is
just terrific that's true of all of the
daniel craig bond films right all of
them open with just this great sequence
this one opens with this terrific
sequence where he has to basically run
through a small italian city and he's
taking motorcycles upstairs and he's
flying over things in the the classic
aston martin it's really cool it's about
15 minutes into the film after the
credits things start to go off the rails
pretty quickly because the big problem
with this movie is that the plot makes
no sense at all
i am your character let's start with
bond's actual character trajectory this
bond because he was essentially
monogamous from casino royale right he's
in love with this one woman and then
he's with her for a couple of movies and
then he moves on to leia do and he's
monogamous with her right he's a serial
monogamist because of that there was
only one way for his trajectory to go
and that was eventually he was gonna get
married and settle down right so the
entire plot relies on him kind of
becoming the responsible guy who's going
to settle down well the minute that
happens either he has to retire and he
has to go off to pasture or you have to
kill him so this is the last bond movie
so one of those two things was going to
happen in order for bond to work as a
character he can't become a responsible
dad right if he becomes a responsible
dad then
his character is done right now he's
become like jack ryan or like any other
tom clancy hero the whole point of bond
is that he's suave and he's dub an air
and all of this sort of stuff and given
the fact that it would have no emotional
stakes if he just sort of retired and
went off and lived with leah and his kid
they were going to kill him and it was
pretty obvious i would say from the
middle of the movie on that that was the
trajectory of the film was was that he
was eventually going to die so if you're
going to kill bond you have to kill bond
in a pretty dramatic fashion right and
he has to face up against a great
villain historically kind of speaking in
terms of literature take sherlock holmes
most iconic literary heroes sherlock
holmes in the original iteration by
arthur conan doyle he actually dies
right he was sick of writing sherlock
holmes and so what he did is he had him
fighting moriarty who is his arch enemy
and then they both go tumbling off a
waterfall together now he ended up
bringing sherlock holmes back a couple
of years later because the outcry was so
great that he'd killed holmes but if
you're going to take out your hero your
hero has to simultaneously take out the
big bad guy right the big villain okay
well here is the problem the villain in
this movie just sucks the villain in
this movie is garbage and none of
nothing makes sense because the villain
sucks you can cut out the entire middle
sequence of the film you can literally
have the first five minutes of the film
before the action sequence and the last
five minutes of the film
and miss the entire middle of the film
and plot wise you've missed very little
that is because the villains in these
pieces matter i don't know how they blew
it that badly
the entire movie starts with this
flashback sequence from lacey dude's
character she's growing up she's got an
alcoholic mom her dad is an assassin on
behalf of spectre presumably and this
guy comes tromping across the snow to a
small house in the middle of nowhere and
proceeds to kill the mom because her dad
has killed this guy's entire family okay
then she tries to run away from this
assassin ends up under the ice and the
assassin instead of killing her saves
her and then we get the entire sequence
with bond where they're running away
from spectre and they're running away
from the bad guys and bond puts her on a
train because he no longer trusts her he
thinks that she's working for spectre
because of the last movie hey fast
forward five years now for some odd
reason again nothing makes sense here
for some odd reason mi6 trusts her
implicitly like trust her so much that
they're allowing her to be the only
person who talks with blofeld
why is this the case and if this is the
case why hasn't this at any point been
explained to james bond right like they
were lovers they were sleeping together
as it turns out he impregnated her like
at no point does anybody think to pick
up the phone and call bond be like by
the way you know your entire assessment
of this situation was completely wrong
instead they're like nah we're just
going to use her as the psychiatrist
we'll keep it secret from bond and we'll
let him drink his way out of it in
jamaica or something okay so already
this makes no sense it turns out the big
baddie is not blofeld it would have been
really interesting right they have him
in the movie like christoph wallace
plays him in the movie again and they
have him in the movie as a sort of weird
hannibal lecter-like figure right they
have like a very dramatic scene where
he's in a glass cage and he's tied down
and they kind of wheel him out and then
he faces down
james bond and all this and he's in the
movie for like five minutes but he's not
the big villain the big villain is a
rammy mallet character who has no clear
motivation and as it turns out is the
guy who saved leia's character when she
was a teenager who for some reason both
wants to murder everyone on earth and
also has become strangely obsessed with
layup for a reason that we have no idea
about like so obsessed that he is
willing to put in danger his entire plan
to kill millions of humans because he
wants to kidnap this woman
and presumably do something with her
that is never made clear keep her in his
thrall but also take her kid who is
james bond's kid and this is the person
who james bond is supposed to
be tracking down it's a like it makes no
sense it is it is completely bizarre and
it is real step down from blowfeld who
actually runs this giant worldwide
organization what does romney malek's
big plan i just don't understand he
kidnaps leicester he kind of locks her
in a room and then he's like well she's
not important to me this child is
important to me the kid bites him and
then he's like okay child be free so
what did we go through this whole
rigmarole for you could have like if you
want to kill her or kill the kid you
could have done that a thousand times in
like why so you bring them to this
stupid island you're like this child is
so precious to me i'll threaten to kill
the child the child is my leverage and
then you're like oh the kid bit me
little
sh get out of here like what what are
you doing bad parenting strategy also
bad kidnapping strategy also bad villain
strategy generally so then we have the
mission right the mission is that there
is this scientist and the scientist of
course has the the macguffin and the
mcguffin is this virus that is going to
infect and kill millions of people
across the world but is genetically
coded so it's only going to kill certain
types of people and originally this was
created as a british government project
designed to kill off members of spectre
or kill off just specific people but
then it was grabbed and perverted by the
big daddy there's a great action
sequence in cuba where anna de armas
she's the best thing in the movie anna
armas not only is she a beautiful woman
obviously but also she plays the
character
really funny like she like she pretends
that she doesn't really know what she's
doing but then she really knows what
she's doing like again all of the action
sequences are very good they just don't
make any sense in the context of the
plot
okay and all of this is being
contributed to by the fact that mi6 has
now replaced bond with the new double 07
who is a black woman whose name i do not
recall because it's completely
unimportant who she is in the story like
she's just a throwaway joke and she's
utterly incompetent now if you actually
wanted to make bond's replacement as
double 07 a black woman who is
completely competent and the idea is
that james bond himself is sort of on
the downslope of his career he can't
handle it anymore he's kind of fallen
apart he's dissolute right you could
totally do that but instead she's
terrible she's a terrible agent her
entire role consists of sucking at
everything she's bad we'll get some more
in just one second first does it make
sense that the same company that
controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home big tech is more
powerful than most countries are at this
point and they profit by exploiting your
personal data it's time to put a layer
of protection between your online
activity and the tech juggernauts that's
why i use expressvpn think about how
much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit every video
you watch every message you send is
tracked datamined when you run
expressvpn on your device however the
software hides your ip address something
bigtech can use to personally identify
you so expressvpn makes your activity
harder to trace and sell to advertisers
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network what i like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use you
just open up your phone you click on the
app right now not connected boom i hit
that connected protected it's that
simple and expressvpn does all of that
without slowing your connection that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by cnet and wired so stop
handing over your personal data to big
tech they'll mine your activity they'll
sell your information protect yourself
with the vpn i trust to keep me safe
online go check them out right now
expressvpn.com to get three extra months
for free
all of this leads to you know the big
confrontation at the end which is really
kind of erotic and silly in which rami
malik has created an iteration of the
virus that is only going to affect
leiasidu and the daughter who is james
bond's kid he infiltrates the island
with double07 and finally you get to the
end and rami malik shoots him a couple
of times and then he has a fight with
rami malek where he beats the hell out
of romney malacan in the process rami
malek scratches him with this vial which
makes it impossible for him to touch
leah sidoo and the daughter if he ever
does then they both die and then james
bond kind of shoots him to death and
then we get james bond's death because
he's ordered the missiles to be launched
at this island where all the bad stuff
is where the macguffin is and it's
supposed to be super moving now again i
understand what the writers are trying
to do they're actually softening the
blow of him dying because the minute
that he can't touch leo or his daughter
and there's no way to fix that which is
made clear 87 times in the movie once
that happens and then you figure okay
well what's he going to do like is he
going to just you know touch them with
gloves is it going to be covered forever
with james bond and his wife and kid
like how's that going to work so they
have to kill him off at that point
on a scale of one to ten i give this one
like a six like it's it's a fun watch
mainly because frankly i'm a big fan of
james bond's new omega seamaster 300 m
which is quite a nice watch i really
like the titanium bracelet on that
socket that's that's a nice watch with
the botina and everything really good uh
best things about it daniel craig is
always a great and entertaining bond
christoph walls for five minutes is
great for like the five minutes that
he's in it ray finds is fine
no no pun intended the action sequences
particularly the first action sequence
very very solid hey the worst things
about it i don't know who wrote the
script or why the plot is the way that
it is why i mean it's very long it's
like a two hour 35 two hour 40 minute
movie it sort of wanders here and there
and never quite gets anywhere and kills
off characters randomly and then they're
they're all making dumb decisions that
don't make any sense rami malek's
character no leia's involvement at the
crossroads of every plot point no like
everything revolves around leicester
right no one knows why like why is
leicester the goat between for blowfelt
why is lacydu the object of obsession
for the guy who happens to want to kill
half the planet
why is mi6 truck right none of that
makes any sense i have a
visceral dislike
for people making bad decisions in
movies a good movie has everybody making
understandable decisions at the time but
then the consequences are bad because
that's usually how people act right you
make a decision it's very rarely like
completely difficult but everyone in
this movie is just making stupid
decisions over and over and over again
and then the results are bad and then
we're supposed to be like shocked that
the results are super bad final pet
peeve i'm the father of a seven-year-old
a five-year-old and one and a
half-year-old the kid in this movie is
the most obedient
quiet easy child i've ever seen and they
never explained this i feel like they
were five seconds from explaining this
because ramy malek at one point actually
points to a plant and he says this plant
makes you obedient and i was like oh
that's why the kid isn't screaming and
pissing on him the kid is what is the
kid in this movie maybe four or five
probably right okay so my son's age if
you ever met a five-year-old or a
four-year-old like i don't know who the
scriptwriters are or if they've ever met
a child there is no child in the world
who goes to a creepy russian dude after
being ripped away from his mother and
the kid's like
okay of all the suspension of
disbelieved things that was the
suspension of disbelief thing that got
me most and i'm perfectly willing to go
with a car that has a mini gun in the
headlights i'm perfectly willing to go
with a virus that kills people based
solely on their dna but i am not willing
to go with four-year-old who acts like
that that is not real okay that is not a
real thing as a parent people who are
saying this is kind of like an emotional
send-off for bond and all this if you
want to make an emotional send off for
bond then he has to fight the big baddie
and the big baddie can't be rami malik
brought in to make weird faces and speak
with a strange accent for two hours with
no discernible motive or purpose other
than to just be there so james bond can
kill him and die in the process
especially because blofeld's a character
in the film you know how close they were
to actually making this film like
terrific blofeld is controlling things
from inside the prison that's a really
interesting premise right what if the
first 20 minutes of the film isn't the
first 20 minutes of the film what if
that's all two hours of the film right
meaning that he doesn't know whether he
can trust leo sedu or not he loves her
he's having a kid with her and now he
faces the conflict of not knowing
whether she's working for the baddies or
not within 30 seconds of him seeing her
again he knows she's not working for the
baddies again so all that tension is
gone what if the internal tension here
is between james bond as agent and james
bond as man who wants relationship with
wife and child and in the end he makes
the wrong decision because he thinks
that they're the bad guys but it turns
out they're not the bad guys and in the
process he has to take down blowfeld and
sacrifice himself what if that were the
story instead of this whole remy malik
side plot that makes no sense at all
bottom line should you watch the movie
sure it's fun it's it's definitely worth
seeing in theaters it's the first movie
that i've seen in theaters with my wife
for about two years and for that purpose
it was really fun and and kind of a
blast but overall disappointed with it
and uh and wish it could have been more